Mathematically speaking, the
Chebyshev inequality is just a
simple application of the
Markov inequality.
However, it contains a somewhat
different message.
Consider a random variable
that has a
certain mean and variance.
What the Chebyshev inequality
says is that if the variance
is small, then the random
variable is unlikely to fall
too far off from the mean.
If the variance is small, we
have little randomness.
And so X cannot be too
far from the mean.
In more precise terms, we have
the following inequality.
The probability that the
distance from the mean is
larger than or equal to a
certain number is, at most,
the variance divided by the
square of that number.
So if the variance is small, the
probability of falling far
from the mean is also
going to be small.
And if the number c is large, so
that we're talking about a
large distance from the mean,
then the probability of this
event happening falls
off at a rate at
least 1 over c squared.
By the way, I should add here
that c is assumed to be a
positive number.
If c was negative, then the
probability that we're looking
at would be equal to 1 anyway.
And there isn't any point in
trying obtain a bound for it.
To prove the Chebyshev
inequality, we will apply the
Markov equality as follows.
The probability of interest is
the same as the probability
that the square of this quantity
is larger than or
equal to the square of c.
But now, here we have a
non-negative random variable.
And we can apply the Markov
inequality with X replaced by
this random variable and with
a replaced by c squared.
So this gives us the expected
value of the random variable
of interest divided
by c squared.
But we recognize that the
numerator is just the variance.
And this is the Chebyshev
inequality that we claimed.
As an application of the
Chebyshev inequality, let us
look at the probability of this
event that the distance
from the mean is at least k
standard deviations, where k
is some positive number.
Using the Chebyshev inequality
with c replaced by k times
sigma, we obtain sigma squared
over c squared, which in our
case is k squared times
sigma squared,
which is 1 over k squared.
So what this is saying is that
if you take, for example, k
equal to 3, the probability that
you fall three standard
deviations away from the mean
or more, that probability is
going to be less than or
equal to 1 over 9.
And this is true no matter
what kind of
distribution you have.
Let us now revisit our earlier
example, where X is an
exponential random variable.
And we're interested in the
probability that the random
variable takes a value larger
than or equal to a.
The Markov inequality gave
us a bound of 1 over a.
And as we recall, the exact
answer to this probability was
e to the minus a.
Let us see what we can get
using the Chebyshev
inequality.
Now, our random variable
has a mean of 1.
Let us assume that a is bigger
than 1, so that we're
considering an event that we
fall far away from the mean by
a distance of at least
a minus 1.
That is we write the probability
that X is larger
than or equal to a as the
probability that the distance
of X from the mean is larger
than or equal to a minus 1.
And now, this event is smaller
than the event that the
absolute value of X minus 1
is larger than a minus 1.
This is because if this event is
true, then that event will
also be true.
And now, we can apply the
Chebyshev inequality.
Here we have the distance
of X from the mean.
So the Chebyshev inequality
applied to the random variable
X will have up here
the variance of X,
which is equal to 1.
And in the denominator, we will
have a minus 1 squared.
Notice that if a is a large
number, this quantity here
behaves like 1 over a squared,
which falls off much faster
than 1 over a.
So at least for large a's, the
Chebyshev bound is going to
give us a smaller bound and,
therefore, more informative
than what we obtained from
the Markov inequality.
In most cases, the Chebyshev
inequality is, indeed,
stronger and more informative
than the Markov inequality.
And one of the reasons is that
it exploits more information
about the distribution of the
random variable X. That is it
uses knowledge, not just
about the mean
of the random variable.
But it also uses some
information about the variance
of the random variable.